[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just tap into the group chat live in
the bleacher report app
presented by fanduel i'm greg ivory
alongside live moods live it is
great to have you back welcome back
i don't know i think i think you might
be muted liv but i i know that you're
welcoming me and telling me that you're
welcome to uh that you're happy to be
back but as always we are here giving
away locks
we're giving away hoodies we're giving
away jerseys and uh liv let's just get
this thing going i need everybody to get
in the comments because i need gifts i
need emojis but most importantly i need
winners only please in fact
i'm feeling so generous i'm about to hop
into these comments because
i'm about to give out a jersey right now
um to somebody in the comments i see uh
maxwell rexella's in the comments saying
that he's rocking with the warriors
tonight shout out to you maxo rescue uh
oh hold on
i see michael epps once lonzo and caruso
comes back bulls are gonna be ex uh
unstoppable
shout out to you mike x01
you are
walking away
with uh a jersey and and i'm gonna get
back into the comments because i want to
give out a hoodie why not uh i see
snoopy snoopy 2153 he gave us
the sunsets he gave us the sunsets vibes
and if you guys know sunsets i i have a
real they hold a real close place to my
heart uh but it is
tnt
thursday which means we are betting the
three by two today
the question is
will there be two three pointers in the
first three minutes
of
the game tonight
last week our three by two parlay cashed
let's take a look at the highlights
first one
gary jackson jr with the pop and that
game uh that 3x2 was finished by al
horford right there
and in the la match up terence man got
it cracking with the first three and
braun
finished it off for the parlay braun
took it on home for a sliv
we hit last week let's get rich again
this week everybody because we asked you
on twitter which 3x2 will catch tonight
is it the sixers taken on the nets or is
it my golden state warriors taking on
liv's denver nuggets here are the
results
wow wow 67
rocking with the philly brooklyn game uh
and only 33 rocking with the denver
golden state game live
i but i need everybody to get in the
comments and tell me which 3x2 is a lock
live talk to me talk to the people
which 3x2 do you think is a lot tonight
first of all sorry about my sound i
think the betting gods were telling me
to stay away from the nuggets and the
warriors because they knew i was gonna
bet with my heart so there's the first
thing but
uh all four of these teams tonight
ranked top ten in three point defense
however the golden state warriors ranked
third and three-pointers attempted and
made and denver ranks 11th in
three-pointers attempted and 10th in
three-pointers made so i'm actually
fading the public and i'm kind of
leaning towards the warriors and the
nuggets here for this three by two
liv i i mean
anytime the splash brothers are on the
court and it's and it's anything dealing
with three pointers i mean it's smart to
kind of go with you know historically
speaking with it'll be smart to go with
the splash brothers if we're talking
threes so i don't dislike you for that i
don't dislike your bet
but uh let me see what these comments
are talking about gotta see what these
comments are talking about hey eddie
says denver warriors game shout out to
you a eddie you're walking away with a
hoodie m taylor90 says philly brooklyn
is a lock shout out to you m taylor you
are also walking away with eddie i got
one more comment one more hoodie to give
away
uh br betting's in the comments and both
of these are hitting d'angelo ortiz 23
says philly brooklyn 3x2 is fire
live we are riding
the people are riding we're going to
ride the philadelphia 76ers and the
brooklyn nets 3x2 but that do not mean
that does not mean
we shouldn't sprinkle the other game
because denver nuggets golden state we
talked about it splash brothers it's
also a good bet so sprinkle around the
board but now it's my favorite time of
the show live because we get to talk
major markets money lines against the
spreads and point totals for tonight's
game let's take a look at the odds
live talk to me talk to the people here
what are you seeing and um what do you
like
i can't believe i'm about to say this
greg but i know you'll like it i'm
taking the warriors on the money line
tonight yes the nuggets are my home team
however this is a nuggets team that is
playing on a back to back and they are
five and seven straight up on no rest
the warriors have a rest advantage here
and it's worth noting that this warriors
bench only lost by seven points the last
time that they played denver on monday
and the starters are back you've got
curry thompson and wiggins back in the
mix and as for this warriors defense
they're giving up the fifth fewest
points per game to their opponent right
now i just think they have the advantage
of rest their starters are playing again
they've got strong defense it's hard not
to go with the warriors tonight so i'm
taking warriors money line
yeah liv i am right there behind you
you're taking money line i'm saying take
the spread uh you mentioned not a couple
days ago the warriors went to denver
and they they they they sent the team
out there that that didn't feature
majority of their starters it was the
backup guys it was a lot of their
rookies it was the bench guys role
players and they barely lost
while that game was happening those
starters was getting rest so i think
they're going to be well rested
traveling to denver
and taking up uh taking on this this
nuggets team that you mentioned live
it's the second game of a back-to-back
steph likes to put on the show in denver
i'm rocking with the warriors minus two
but let me hop into these comments
let me hop into these comments and see
what they are talking about dj fitz live
dj fitness in the comments says tobias
harris rebounds and assists over eight
and a half is super fire
i like that i actually do like that so
shout out to you dj fitch you are
walking away with a hoodie uh
jojo473454 says warriors winning
covering the spread
and take the money line
shout out to you jojo you're just trying
to get it however you get it and i see
it so uh you are walking away with the
hoodie as well
liv
we talked major markets now let's talk
player props
because it's time for lock or not i'm
going to put up a prop and i need
everybody to get in the comments and
tell me whether it is a lock or it's not
liv let's get right to it first up is
clay thompson
to make two or more three pointers
sitting at -118
talk to me live talk to the people do
you think this is a lock or not
i actually do think this is a lock i
mean as i mentioned when i was talking
about three 3x2 there's a lot of
three-point shooters on this warriors
team and klay thompson is one of them
he's hit this over in four of the last
five and went three for ten from the
three versus denver in their last
meeting uh if there's one thing and you
know this better than anybody because
you're a warriors fan if there's one
thing that i know about klay thompson
it's that he is gonna take the shot and
if he went three for ten he put up ten
shots versus the nuggets last time he's
gonna have a similar performance tonight
so i really do like him to make two plus
threes tonight i think it's a lock
i like that later but i like what you
said uh
well something that i'm learning liv
something that i'm learning when betting
these uh player props and we're betting
three pointers you know we're betting uh
like klay thompson to score two or more
three players you usually want to bet on
the guy that's gonna take the shots or
you're you're gonna be pulling your hair
watching that game hoping that that guy
takes your time
so in this situation klay thompson he
puts up three-pointers we know that
that's what he's gonna do they call him
a splash brother for a reason
you mentioned he put up 10 the last time
he faced the nuggets he's a future hall
of famer he's known for making threes
i'm gonna put my money that he's gonna
make too i think this one's a lock
sitting at minus 118 let me get into the
comments though because i want to see
what they're talking about i got jones
jordan says clay equals jackie moon it
is a lot shout out to you jones jordan
uh you were walking away with a hoodie
also see 90 buckets lock don't bet
against the sharpshooter we all know
clay is one of the sharpshooters on the
warriors uh so i'm loving the vibes in
the comments i'm loving the vibes in the
comments plumlee for heisman says lock
lock lock and he gave us a gift you in
the beginning of the show we did ask for
gifts so shout out to everybody that i
mentioned you all are walking away with
hoodies next up live we have nicole
yokic to have 14 plus rebounds
this one's sitting at plus
102 live now we know the warriors they
struggle with size so do you like this
one is this one a lock or not
yeah you said it they do struggle with
size and i think this is a whole
different conversation when they have a
healthy draymond green but we're not
there quite yet i do think this is a
lock i mean this is nicole joke which
we're talking about and the warriors
have struggled against opposing centers
in the last seven they're giving up the
most points to opposing centers in the
last seven and
rebounding wise where is the size just
like you said if it's looney versus
jokic in a match up i'm taking jokic
every time he averages 17 versus the
warriors this season he's hit this over
and for the last five and the warriors
are giving up an average of 14.18
to opposing centers in the last seven
and jokic and the word average being in
the same sentence just does not make
sense so i do think it's a lock
yeah the joke it's in the word average
that doesn't make sense and and looney
versus jokic i'm taking jokic every
single time uh liv 14 is a lot i'm not
going to lie 14 is a lot but i mentioned
the one achilles heel for the golden
state warriors this year
is their size they it's it's just the
fact and jokic mvp contender
liv i'm riding with you i'm taking the
rebounds i'll take i'll i like it i'll
take the over uh but let's see i'm gonna
see what the people in the comments are
talking about see what they're talking
about oh hey look at nadia nadia's back
in the comments says joker is too big
for them that is a fact joker is too big
for them um
let me see i see
i see
a in car
wow producer i'm i'ma spell it out
a-e-n-c-a-r-n-a-c-i-o-n
97 yes you you were walking away with a
hoodie he has the yoker gift uh jokic
gift so um
shout out to you last but not least liv
last but not least we're talking about
steph wardell curry
and he only has to score 24 tonight
only has to put up 24 tonight sitting at
-112
talk to me liv do you think those is a
lock or not
you mentioned this before show three
months ago this bet would have terrified
me but right now i think he's on fire
we're seeing the steph curry that we
know and love the second half of the
splash brothers i think there's gonna be
a lot of threes in this game i think he
plays a big role in that and not to
mention denver is giving up the sixth
most points per game to opposing point
guards in the last seven at
28.24 so steph curry tonight for 24 plus
in a very competitive western conference
matchup with a warriors team that is
really struggling to hold on to that
second spot in the western conference
this is absolutely a perfect moment for
a guy like steph curry to show up show
out and get the job done so i do love
him for 24 plus i think it's also a lock
one thing i've mentioned is that the
warriors players were resting the last
time these two teams played a couple
days ago
they're gonna come in here
well rested dimmers on the back to back
i could see my guy steph curry going to
score 24 points yes liv i did mention it
before the beginning of the show if you
guys would have gave me this three
months ago i would have laughed at you i
would have laughed and took this to the
bank and cashed this one easy
i'm still laughing at this one liv
because 24 i know steph's been
struggling with no draymond but
i think he can go do it he usually when
he plays in colorado
i seen steph goes up to the male high
city and i don't know if it's something
about the altitude or whatever he comes
out there and he puts on the show so i'm
rocking with the over but let me hop
into the comments liv let me hop into
the comments
because i got
tour 718 says curry's going for 35 plus
tonight it is a lock shout out to you
taurus 718 i also see goated swayze says
lock steph curry is on fire shout out to
both of you guys you guys are walking
away with some br betting hoodies live
i'm
excited because i'm ready to build this
br betting custom same game parlay which
you guys can ride with us on fanduel
tonight we are looking at the 76ers
netscape
i need everybody to get in the comments
and tell
me what they think which legs or locks
which legs or not live let's get right
to it and we are starting off with that
man
kevin durant
yesterday winners only was launched we
launched winners only right here on the
br app and i talked about kevin durant's
take to a fan being upset at kevin
durant for laying an egg in the
charlotte game live i think you you told
me that you you bet on his point total
in his last matchup but
i want to say kevin durant basically
told that fan he told him like hey i
don't care about your bets but usually
when when kevin durant gets on twitter
and use those twitter fingers
he's coming out with a vengeance in the
next game so i
like this one a lot liv and i hope i
sold you on it i hope i did enough to
sell you on it so talk to me talk to the
people do you like this bet or
you're not really rocking with it
you're very convincing uh seller here
because i i do i like it and any any
given night 25 plus for durant i don't
sweat it of course i'm having a little
bit of some nerves about it because i
did take his over 29 and a half points
last game versus the hornets but he's
facing a 76ers team that's given up the
fourth most points to opposing small
forwards in the last seven this is a
great spot for him to one have a bounce
back but two there's a lot of story
lines around this game kind of showing
what they're made of you know playing in
front of former teammate james harden uh
eastern conference rivalry there's just
a lot going on here great spot for him
to bounce back and to hit 25 plus for
sure
liv you mentioned it you mention it
going against his former teammate
and that leads me to the next leg of
this part like james harden 25 plus
points
now
the way james harden left you know he
wasn't playing before he left and
the kyrie came out and said something in
the media about the way he left kevin
durant also addressed it
i think that
this one
they're gonna go out there trying to
make a statement both teams so i i i can
see these superstars scoring a lot of
points believe
i'm just trying to i'm just trying to
talk to you i'm just trying to convince
you to like this james harden one so
talk to me talk to the people do you
like this james harden
uh point total as well
i mean yeah like again i he's totally
capable of scoring 25 plus without
question especially facing his former
team but i do think a little bit that
harden is the type of guy that's okay
with sacrificing points if it means that
the 76ers win because in the end a win
is a whole lot better than just your
personal stats for this game i mean this
is again a very competitive uh eastern
conference rivalry facing his former
team however yeah i do think this is a
great opportunity for him to show that
he's capable of both facilitating and
scoring i worry that i don't necessarily
know what his role is going to be is he
going to do more facilitating and feed
the ball to embiid or is he going to
score more this is a great game to show
that he is capable of both and that he
made the right move um in moving to the
76ers so yeah i think he's gonna have a
great night all around
this is a big statement game for both
teams
and big time players usually come to
play
when when the lights are bright and joel
embiid is a big time player live but i'm
not talking points here not talking
points here i'm talking rebounds joel
embiid to get 10 plus rebounds tonight
i'm not even going to try to convince
you on this one i just want you to talk
to me do you like this one or do you not
yeah i mean joel embiid getting 10 plus
rebounds it seems silly to even say it
or question it because he's just so
dominant
and again he's playing at an mvp caliber
he's been in conversation and been the
favorite for a while now um so yeah i
think it's a great play and i also think
that not having lamarcus aldridge is
helping him out immensely here because i
don't really see a solid big man on the
nets being able to control him now yes
i'm sure the comment section right now
is saying what about andre drummond i
didn't forget about him i know he's
playing but again drummond versus embiid
i'm gonna take him beat every time and i
really don't think there's a guy that
can get him under control so rebounds
great play love it and 10 plus for
embiid seems like a walk in the park
liv likes it she thinks it's a walking
apart aka a layup
so uh
i'm i'm liking it too
but last but not least liv i don't know
if this one we can call the layup i
don't know if we can call layup and
usually when it's three plus or more
unless the man name is stephen curry i
get kind of hesitant
but we're talking about uncle true here
kyrie irving future hall of famer we can
say it
can he go out and make three three
pointers tonight three plus three
pointers talk to me talk to the people
do you like this leg
i mean if there's a guy on either one of
these teams that's gonna wanna uh be a
ball hog not pass take every shot he
possibly can it's a guy like kyrie
irving and i don't mean that
disrespectfully but we just know that
it's true
not to mention he's coming off of a game
where he was nine for 12 from the three
he dropped a 50 piece on the hornets
he's going to carry over some of that
momentum he's going to try to show james
harden this is what you're missing out
on and we don't need you to win
absolutely he is going to be showboating
tonight so three plus threes coming off
of a night where he was shooting 70 or
yeah 75 percent from the three he's
going to carry over momentum i like this
leg a lot
liv likes it uh we okay we got good
vibes we got good vibes but uh
let me pull the ticket up because i want
to show you guys if we would put a
hundred dollars down you're walking away
with 480
dollars in three cents do not forget
about the sins
speaking of james hard we partner we
partner with our friends over at fanduel
for a special boost for tonight liv tell
the people what's up
that's right you guys fanduel is
offering a super boost that i actually
really love sometimes i get a little
nervous about super boost and i don't
want to get drawn into them too quick
but i love this one it is hardened to
have 10 plus assists and the 76ers to
win
boosted from 110 to 150 so if you like
it as much as i do you know the drill
head over to the phantom sports book
place it yourself let's make some money
but i really do like this boost tonight
a lot
i like that liv said you know the drill
hey but
i like this liv if james heart i mean in
order for them to win james harden needs
to have a good game and in order for i
mean
when him having a good game that means
him facilitating the ball as well as
scoring so
10 assists and a win
boost it up to plus 150 i like it a lot
but before i get into the comments let's
get back to this parlay
what are you creating the the same game
parley live
i'm gonna give this one a solid a minus
you know first show back i don't want to
grade us too high get a little too cocky
a little too comfortable here so a minus
but i really like this game or this
parlay uh especially because this game
again lots of story lines big statement
game for both teams so you're gonna
depend on these four guys right here to
show up show out and do their job and i
think that's exactly what we're gonna
see tonight so i really like it i'm
giving it an a minus
we got good vibes from liv now let me
give some good vibes to the people in
the comments for sticking around and
giving us good takes i see t
j sloshy 73 says two of these guys are
getting 50 plus they think it's going to
be a shootout in this one um goat garden
go go go garden you deserve a hoodie for
this
actually go garden i'm giving you a
jersey b-minus for good luck and he gave
us some weak emojis that's how we know
bill garden is here week after week and
is a real loyal yeah to the soil type of
fan because when liv gives us b minuses
we usually win
so live garden i see you you're walking
away with a jersey you're smart you are
very smart
let me give away a hoodie one more one
more i see anthony thompson
says a plus lock on the parlay thank you
for the good vibes anthony you are
walking away
with a hoodie um liv the nets and sixers
are both playing out of their minds
right now if you had to choose today
which would be your best bet to win the
nba title
the nets
or the 76ers
i gotta go with the 76ers here i mean
they've got the better established
chemistry obviously the nets are
starting to form that chemistry now that
kyrie and kd are able to play a little
bit more together but the chemistry is
going to change good or bad it's going
to change when ben simmons gets thrown
into the mix so i'm liking that the
76ers already have that established
chemistry and are having time to
continue to play off of that chemistry
they've also got an mvp caliber big man
solid offense at the hands of point
guard james harden and a top 10 defense
so all around if i've got a pick between
the 76ers and the nets i'm gonna rock
with the 76ers for those reasons alone
but especially because the value is
better and i know you like value here
greg so i'm gonna rock with the 76ers
i like that liv i like that but today we
asked you all in the f who would you
like to see win
the title more is it the next or the
sixers i need everybody to get in the
comments and tell me who you want to win
the nba title uh who you can see winning
the nba title is it the next or the
76ers
let's take a look at those updated odds
they just pulled them up but pull those
updated odds back up because liv now
we're talking the whole nba
are you still rocking with those 76ers
to win it all
yeah i like the 76ers still a lot but i
do you know obviously have my eyes still
on the golden state warriors at plus
480. uh they're not fully healthy as you
talked about earlier draymond green is
supposedly making a return this coming
monday against the wizards so adding him
back into the mix i really love and i'm
sure there's a lot of people tuning in
right now going what about the suns how
disrespectful they're strong on both
sides of the ball you're right they are
but there is something in my butter in
my better's gut that is telling me the
suns are going to choke and i can't
explain it i just can see it happening i
feel like they picked up momentum a
little too soon a little too quick and i
feel a little bit of a plateau coming
where they're just kind of playing and
and the warriors have every opportunity
they're still winning games without
draymond green but draymond green is
coming back james wiseman as you
mentioned potentially back
i just got a rock with the warriors here
as well as the 76ers i'm not sold on the
suns
and i'm sorry about that sun's nation
but i'm just not so i'm gonna rock with
the warriors and the 76ers
liv i am right there with you i'm
literally right there with you let's
talk about the 76ers i went on record
and i said that i felt like the brooklyn
nets won that trade and i still do feel
that way
but i might go back on my word liv if
james harden leaves that's the 76th
year's team to a championship because
that's literally what this this trait
was about they they traded me right they
were trying to take that next step in
order to win a championship so
i i like the way they're playing in
philadelphia my eyes have been open
since the trade and i've been seeing it
so i like them and you know me liv you
you mentioned it earlier i like value
and the 7 the 76ers have i mean they
have the better value out of the the
better team so i'm rocking with the
76ers
out of the east and if i was to sprinkle
on the west i am actually going to
spring along the west this is actually
my favorite bet
the golden state warriors the golden
state warriors they
they have the pieces i'm not surprised
what it takes
draymond's coming back iguodala who is a
finals mvp yes he's coming back and i
heard
i heard from sources my man james widens
it james wiseman is uh going to play a
g-league game soon uh so that means he
also will be coming back soon so watch
out for those golden state warriors but
liv
it's a hot topic in the nba world right
now speculation started after his
comments following the nba all-star game
the lakers lose another tough one last
night
do you see lebron in la next season
i honestly don't i mean he's obviously
made comments that he wants to play with
his son brawny and we know lebron james
likes to win those are two things that i
don't think are gonna happen in la so
i don't think he stays but you know what
maybe his loyalty to them is deeper than
i think it is he does seem pretty
checked out to me this year with this
lakers team so i don't see it um
but who knows who knows maybe his
loyalty is deeper than i think it is
yeah i i really don't see it either liv
uh
my man my man brian knows what he's
doing we're talking about it for a
reason there's speculation for a reason
it's it's not no accident so uh i
honestly i don't see it unless the war
elects the lakers make some uh some
changes they have to make some changes
to get that roster a winning roster but
i did say the warriors and maybe lebron
james is on the golden state warriors
with stephen curry and klay thompson and
all the shooters and he could just pass
the ball he doesn't even need to be you
know the the scoring first force that he
is in la this year he could just you
know go win some championships the easy
way but who knows who knows
but but
what i do know is it's time to give away
some more hoodies uh so i need everybody
to get in the comments
because i'm looking for some takes oh i
see enderman enderman has sunset sunsets
is the way sunsets have a close they're
sunsets
they have a spot in my heart so i'm
enderman you were walking away with a
hoodie i also see
trigger way trigger way he says true
that i think he says true that to what
we were just talking about liv
um and lebron james so shout out to you
trigger way you are also walking away
with the hoodie uh
i see lakers bond uh oh this one might
be good lebron got the final year on his
contract in order for him to leave he
gotta demand the trade
he called us goofy all right
laker vaughan 32
lebron james can do whatever he wants to
he's lebron james so if he says that he
doesn't want to play for lakers next
year guess what
lebron james is not going to play for
the lakers next year so
i don't know are we goofy or
you goofy i mean we are but not like
that
i'm in the i'm i'm i'm i'm giving you a
hoodie actually laker von you deserve a
hoodie you're walking away with a hoodie
but live
think for i mean everybody thanks for
tapping into the group chat live it's
time to get on up out of here
presented by fanduel uh remember what
you guys learned today the 3x2 is a lock
b are betting same game parlay is a lot
and we're switching it up on you guys
we'll be back next tuesday giving out
more hoodies more jerseys and more locks
if you want a hoodie today we will dmu
alongside live moods i'm greg ivory we
are leaving the group chat
peace
[Music]
you